joining us now from jupiter in the state
of florida is
erin elmore she's a republican
strategist who worked as a spokesperson
for donald trump during the 2016
presidential election
uh thank you very much indeed for being
with us erin elmore
we've seen from opinion polls that
republicans are divided on what happened
here in washington on wednesday do you
support or condemn the protesters
i don't think anyone in america or
otherwise
is proud of what happened we all should
condemn
all acts of political violence political
violence begets
political violence and that's what we
have seen over the last year here in
america whether it was on
january 6 whether it was burning and
desecration
of saint john's church whether it was
rioting and looting
in philadelphia new york minneapolis
with blm and antifa all acts of violence
political or otherwise should be
completely and utterly
disavowed by everyone including the
media
and do you believe therefore there is a
case against president
trump for uh egging on the protesters
and indeed for his son
uh using terms referring to violence
such as
a fight well i think a fight
that's funny that you say that means a
political fighting fighting for our
country because conservatives
believe in our military and our police
officers and democracy and what's
happening right now
is quite undemocratic i remember maxine
waters
saying if you see a conservative go up
to them in the shopping mall or while
they're eating dinner
that is a fight i remember kamala harris
tweeting
to bail out black lives matter
protesters who destroyed in desecrated
cities
and were involved in the killing of 30
americans over the summer
so i think that that is a fight what
about saying
what about the president saying we're
going to have a march
uh on uh the seat of government uh in
uh of the united states i mean that
amounts to incitement whatever may have
happened in the past doesn't it
it certainly doesn't it's our right as
americans to peaceably protest and
assemble
over the summer all we saw was people
saying that these were mostly peaceful
protests
as my city as a city dweller i had to
flee because it virtually burned
to the ground so to flip the script now
and turn the tides on conservatives is
gaslighting we're not we're no but we're
not talking about that now we're talking
about what happened here of course not
uh no no talk about it all in its
totality well hang on wait a minute no
black lives protesters
uh broke into the u.s capitol no black
lives protesters
committed acts of violence which have
now led to the death
uh of a capital police officer
uh so this is what we're talking about
and we're talking about a president who
frankly
appears to have encouraged that behavior
by calling a rally
on that most sensitive day when the
congress was certifying
uh the election result which i know you
and he don't accept
and then going on to say march on on the
congress i mean
there are those people including
republican senators ben sasse for
example
who say he's disregarded his oath of
office and that therefore
uh the congress uh should take some kind
of action against him
what do you say as a journalist one
should never assume what their guest
believes or thinks i'd be happy to tell
you my views if you shall have them
having said that i think all of these
incidents of violence have to be taken
into totality as a country
and i think the mainstream media ignored
what happened this summer so what i
ask you today is do you disavow the
violence that occurred
over this summer because if we want to
heal as a nation and move forward as a
country as a democracy
we have to disavow all violence i
disavow all violence
it makes me okay in my heart i need
you to do the same thing right now well
i'm i'm i'm not a person involved in
this fight i'm asking you you or someone
so you won't say you disavowed
is a supporter of donald trump what what
well do it do you accept are you shocked
so that wasn't enough so are you shocked
that there appears to have been
a much more gentle treatment of
these uh largely white protesters than
the treatment that's been leaked out by
the police uh to black lives matter
protesters over this
past year wait you're saying nothing
that is grounded in fact or reality
nothing
because you know what all of these
agitators and well i'm i'm actually
saying
i'm actually saying something that the
president-elect of the united states
said yesterday
okay so i'm asking you do you agree with
joe biden
that if these demonstrators had been
black they would have been treated in a
very different way
they would have it would have been
completely ignored by the mainstream
media so he is
right it would have been absolutely
ignored
and called a peaceful protest and we
would have had celebrities and
politicians
bailing them out of jail so yep i
thoroughly agree with joe biden today
no i i was asking you and he was talking
i understood your question he was
talking about how
the the police behave do you believe
there has been
an inequity in the way in which those
demonstrators were treated softly here
on wednesday
we've only had uh a dozen or so arrests
so far in spite of a police officer
being killed
compared to how the demonstrators over
the summer were treated
so now blue lives matter so now we're
not into defunding the police
and we care about the police that is an
interesting
chain of events having said that the
daily mail just reported which is a uk
publication
that all of these agitators yesterday
will be prosecuted under president
trump's statute desecration statute
and what that will happen now is they
are going to go to jail for over a
decade
so these agitators will go to jail
based upon the edict or an executive
order by president
potentially i mean i know you're a
lawyer i mean potentially uh president
trump could go for it
to jail for 10 years under that uh
law which he didn't actually introduce
and certainly increase the penalties
didn't he
um words is not a life possibility
that's the creation statute
well you don't think there could be
action against the president uh for
uh supporting the desecration of capitol
hill
he's the one that wrote the legislation
against it there was absolutely no
support by the president
by any way shape or form that's just
total
leftist media talking head propaganda
right
what about the chances of him being
impeached now do you think
there is a case for that we know that uh
congress
the lower house wants to vote on that we
are hearing that a number of senators
are
even republican senators are quite
sympathetic
what your viewers should know about that
is it is nothing more than a political
move it is political theater because
they actually have great fear
for donald trump they don't want him to
run again in 2024
and the only way that they can prohibit
or stop that is this impeachment sham
so yes i think that that's what many
people might want on the left
but do i think it will be political
suicide for many yes do i think it will
be effective
absolutely not and what about
uh article uh amendment 25 of the
constitution
do you feel that this president
is fit to serve even for another few
days
i think the fitness that we should worry
about is that of joe biden under the
25th amendment
we know that he stumbles on his words
incessantly he appears to be in the
early stages of alzheimer's perhaps
dementia
having to live with two grandparents
with it it's very apparent to me to see
so i think if we're going to start
talking about the 25th amendment
let's be very careful what happens next
i just got to put it to you finally i
know you're in jupiter florida but i
think
many british viewers in particular will
think you are living on another very
strange
planet which has lost touch uh with uh
right and wrong and
political morality what would you say to
them
well your quippy one-liners don't hurt
me very much and what i tell you is
70 plus a million americans voted for
president trump
and those are people just like me who
have family that has served in the
military
who paid for everything that we've ever
earned in our life i wasn't handed
anything by anyone and i am an american
who has traveled all over the world and
respects
great britain and respects australia and
respects every corner of our world
i am the person who supports those who
fight our wars and pay
our taxes so for you to call me anything
anything less
than a proper god-fearing god-loving
american who loves this country and
loves our flag
is shameful and disgusting
okay aeronautical thank you for joining
us